[Musik]
wir fahren das land vier wochen runter
um die korona zahlen runter zu kriegen
und dann rechnen wir ab in der halbzeit
vom november so hat uns die kanzlerin
versprochen wir werden in zwei wochen
oder nacht zwei wochen des
inkrafttretens uns als bund und länder
die da treffen und uns anschauen wo wir
stehen und gegebenenfalls auch
massnahmen anpassen
jetzt sind genau diese zwei wochen
vorbei also jetzt ist halbzeit november
wie geht es jetzt weiter ab dezember das
wollen wir wissen und das besprechen wir
heute mit einer talkrunde mit dem
nrw-ministerpräsidenten armin laschet
mit bayerns ministerpräsident markus
söder mit dem spd chef norbert walter
borjans wir wollen also rausfinden wie
wirkt der lok dauern bis hier hin dass
alles jetzt bei bild beginnen wollen wir
diese spannende diskussionen hier live
im studio in berlin mit dem spd
vorsitzenden norbert walter borjans
ihnen schönen guten abend und mit volker
wissing dem fdp-generalsekretär
also wir haben gerade gehört abrechnung
nach den zwei wochen zum ersten mal
erschien nicht runter was dieser teil
lockte und wieder gebracht hat ganz
persönlich herr walter borjans wie haben
sie ihre kontakte in diesen zwei wochen
jetzt eingeschränkt verzichten sie auf
irgendwas bestimmt ist naja als erstes
schon mal auf jeden restaurantbesuch was
ich gerne mache wenn es wenn die
geöffnet sind und damit verbunden sind
tatsächlich auch eine ganze reihe von
einschränkungen im persönlichen bereich
wo man sich trifft wo man sich weniger
trifft ja doch merkt man
würden sie sagen das ist ja jetzt
wahrscheinlich eher eine schätzfrage sie
kommen auf 75 prozent weniger das ist ja
sehr ambitioniert also wenn wir alle
unsere kontakte auf 75 prozent
reduzieren müssen dass man das ist 75
ist viel
ich würde mal sagen die hälfte ist
weggefallen ob es 75 sind habe ich nicht
genau nachgerechnet geht das als
politiker überhaupt einen witzigen 75
prozent runter wenn wir jetzt alle so
sagen da haben wir verzichten auf
restaurantbesuche das ja keine kunst
habe er alle dicht gibt es irgendetwas
worauf sie wirklich verzichtet haben in
den letzten zwei wochen viele gespräche
die nur telefonisch stattfinden konnten
oder nur im allerkleinsten kreis
meistens im digital telefonisch und wenn
dann wirklich nur mit ganz wenigen
personen im riesenraum das ist schon
auch ein verzicht weil man einer
größeren gruppe diskutieren kann das
manchmal schon fruchtbarer aber was man
nicht machen kann ist natürlich als
politiker aufs reisen verzichten
innerhalb deutschland also die mobilität
muss gewährleistet sein dass ist sollte
privaten gibt es da schon werden einzige
einzelne angehörige bei ihnen
aussortiert die trifft man nicht oder
achten sie ganz strikt darauf dass sie
sich auch mit freunden im moment nicht
treffen wie machen sie das ja also
privaten nur die notwendigsten kontakte
in der engsten familie weil dabei auch
bei ihnen ja zumal das muss ich dazu
sagen ist immer wieder auch vorkommt
dass im weiteren bekanntenkreis
tatsächlich personen quarantäne sind und
wo man tatsächlich auch private kontakte
dann über über eine videoschaltung
fliegt die entscheidende frage jetzt
zeigt er locker und der vor zwei wochen
in kraft getreten ist schon seine
wirkung wie sieht man das im moment
unter den spd-ministerpräsidenten spd
minister sie sind selbst in absoluter
zahlen freak sehen sie da schon eine
lockdown wirkung
na ja wir haben um das an einem beispiel
mal zu zeigen wir hatten wochenlang
jetzt ein auto das ständig beschleunigt
hat also das immer schneller wurde von
mal zu mal
und insofern war die entscheidung zu
sagen wir müssen jetzt auf brett auf die
bremse treten und den fuß auch mal
draufhalten eine zeit lang völlig
richtig in der hoffnung das auto wird
langsamer und wir müssen jetzt das sagen
sagen sie sagen es ist nicht mehr hat
ist hat nicht mehr beschleunigt aber es
fehlt oft der hohen geschwindigkeit dies
erreicht hatte praktisch konstant weiter
jetzt kann man sagen 14 tage sind eine
ziemlich kritische größe weil wir wissen
dass vieles erst rund 10 14 tage später
wirkt
und insofern ist natürlich genau diese
halbzeit nicht mit kritische größe das
ist ja auch der grund warum die
kanzlerin jetzt sagt wir treffen uns mit
den ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten
aber in der woche nochmal weil dann
müsste sich dann eigentlich zeigen dass
die bremse auch verlangsamt wenn sie das
nicht tut dann kann sich jeder
vorstellen dass man nicht einfach auf
hoher geschwindigkeit bei uns ja dass
wir nach den zwei wochen erstmal
abrechnen können also wir können jetzt
nicht zwei wochen sagen zwei wochen
später sagen jaja so jetzt haben wir die
zahlen und nicht zusammen singh war
eigentlich klar das hat ja das jahr
bisher gezeigt dass die wirkung eben
verlangsamt erst eintritt
ja das ist einer der vielen punkte der
nicht so ganz logisch ist nicht das wenn
man weiß dass die wirkung etwa erst nach
14 tagen eintritt dass man sagt wir
ziehen nach 14 tagen schon die bilanz
des lok downs von november aber das
hoffe ich wird uns morgen oder im laufe
des tages erklärt werden
lass uns noch mal kurz auf die zahlen
gucken die vom zweiten elfter wie die
sich entwickelt haben ist heute schauen
wir mal auf die landkarte der krone
hotspot so saß am zweiten november aus
in deutschland also an dem tag an dem
der lockdown der neue in kraft getreten
ist rot sind all die gebiete die einen
incidents wert über 50 haben also
wirklich dann risikogebiete innerhalb
deutschlands sind und jetzt schauen wir
mal wie sich das in den zwei wochen
entwickelt haben hat da laufen die tage
hoch und die deutschlandkarte wird eben
nicht blauer oder weniger rot sondern
sie wird noch roter es gibt noch weniger
gebiete die mittlerweile unterhalb
dieses events wert liegen und es gibt
noch eine zweite zahl die ganz
interessant ist nämlich die entwicklung
der neuansteckungen in deutschland in
diesen zwei wochen auch darauf können
wir noch mal kurz den blick werfen also
das sind die zahlen die dann auch morgen
im kanzleramt natürlich auf dem tisch
liegen so sieht die entwicklung in
diesen zwei wochen aus die kleine delle
ist das wochenende so laufen immer die
wochenenden da werden weniger corona
fälle gemeldet und im grunde sind wir
genau da wo wir vor zwei wochen eben
auch standen also jetzt an daten der
zahlen müsste man sagen im grunde keine
wirkung naja also davor blieb es nicht
in dieser wellenbewegung auf einem
niveau
sondern es ging hoch insoferne wirkung
schon nur ich habe das ja eben mit
diesem auto verzichten wenn ich auf
hochgeschwindigkeit weiterfahren
ist das nicht der punkt bei dem ich
sagen kann ich kann den fuß von der
bremse nehmen
und deswegen ist der tag morgen schon
ein wichtiger tag in der 2 insofern ist
es richtig eine woche später sich noch
mal zu treffen aber der morgen auch
darüber befindet was können wir
eigentlich zum ende des monats hin
jedenfalls in aussicht stellen
unser ziel ist es doch gewesen jetzt
erstens früh auf die bremse zu treten
damit wir so was wie die weihnachtszeit
auch möglich machen mit einschränkungen
sowieso aber so dass man sagen kann da
sitzen wir nicht alle allein zu hause
und die frage die sich jetzt stellt ist
geht das indem man anfang dezember schon
wieder den fuß von der bremse nimmt oder
muss man es ein stück weiter machen muss
man möglicherweise in den zwei wochen
bis zum dezember nochmal ein bisschen
stärker durch treten also beispielsweise
die größe von gruppen die sich treffen
darf noch ein stück runter fahren das
sind dinge die kann man schon warum
besprechen und ich bin sicher dass steht
auf der tagesordnung
tatsächlich läuft die diskussion ja
richtung verschärfung deswegen wollen
wir noch mal ganz kurz erinnern wie das
vor zwei wochen lief da gab es ja eine
pressekonferenz im anschluss an diese
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und da war
eben ganz klar davon die rede dass das
eine vier wochen therapie ist deshalb
brauchen wir jetzt im monat november
beginnt vom 2 november noch einmal eine
nationale kraftanstrengung eine
befristete kraftanstrengung die wir auf
die zeit des monats november also bis zu
seinem ende terminieren
die verordnung an die vier wochen
therapie wenn man es sagen kann
unsere hoffnung ist und es wird auch
bestätigt natürlich durch viele experten
dass wir damit eine chance haben wenn
wir vier wochen lang das was wir jetzt
miteinander schließen durchhalten auch
herzlich diese vier wochen
gemeinschaftlich durchzustehen
das dient dem zweck dann im dezember
geht natürlich weiter unter corona
bedingungen das öffentliche leben wieder
besser gestalten zu können so etwa wie
wir es heute kennen
dieser ansatz gilt es für vier wochen
für den november es ist vier wochen sind
harte maßnahmen und harte
einschränkungen die wir jetzt hier
erleben
aber es handelt sich um vier wochen vier
wochen
es hat niemand gesagt dass danach alles
gut wird aber es war ganz klar dass es
eine therapie für vier wochen ist war
das nicht schon augenwischerei wissen
war nicht schon klar zu dem zeitpunkt
das wird man nicht halten können
das weiß ich nicht ich finde es
bemerkenswert dass man jetzt nach zwei
wochen schon wieder verschärfungen
diskutiert wir müssen jetzt erst einmal
abwarten eine mindestens eine weitere
woche um überhaupt rauszukriegen wirkt
dieser lockdown und es gibt ja auch
kritische stimmen die sagen naja die
gastronomie waren bereich der sehr
ausgefeilte hygiene konzepte hatte ob
das wirklich die infektionsherde sind es
gab ja seitens des robert koch instituts
keine hinweise darauf dass jetzt die
infektionen massenweise in der
gastronomie statt drei man gleichzeitig
auch nicht mehr wusste bei 75 prozent
der fällen glaube ich nicht mehr wusste
wo überhaupt die infektion händler aber
das bedeutet natürlich auch dass man ein
stück weit ich sage mal ins blaue hinein
gehandelt hat das kann richtig sein aber
es ist ein experiment man weiß es nicht
nur ich finde man sollte jetzt erst
einmal das experiment evaluieren bevor
man jetzt ein neues experiment watt und
vor allen dingen brauchen wir jetzt ein
bisschen mehr stringenz in der sache
erst den gastronomen zu sagen ihr
braucht ausgefeilte konzepte um dann zu
sagen
trotzdem gehenden konzept machen wir
euch zu ist dieser vor schwer
vermittelbar gewesen
und das hat ja auch zu
akzeptanzproblemen diesen maßnahmen
geführt die viele deutsche können das
nicht nachvollziehen und deswegen finde
ich es jetzt richtig zu evaluieren bevor
wir weitere verschärfungen diskutieren
auf die einzelnen maßnahmen kommen doch
mal gleichviel noch mal auf diese vier
wochen zu sprechen kommen weil das
ebenso eindringlich gesagt wurde
wer das verfolgt hat der wird ich
gehörte dazu er gedacht haben ja gut das
ist jetzt blöd in den vier wochen aber
danach wird es möglicherweise wieder
besser jetzt ist das gegenteil der fall
zwei wochen nur zwei wochen von dieser
pressekonferenz entfernt diskutieren wir
nicht über lockerungen sondern
diskutieren darüber dass es
möglicherweise schlechter wird also
verschärft wird so ganz ehrlich war das
damals nicht ich meine
das ist jetzt der unterschied auch
zwischen opposition und regierung in der
regierung haben sie tatsächlich ein
stück aufsicht zu fliegen also man muss
ganz klar sagen
die absicht war und sie ist immer noch
mit einer bremsung in diesem dezember
möglichkeiten zu schaffen update im
insel im november ab dezember wieder das
leben wieder wie die kanzlerin gesagt
hat unter corona bedingungen ein stück
weiter stattfinden zu lassen kann so
jetzt erleben wir zwei dinge wir leben
erstens dass die länder um uns herum
richtig kritische werte erreichen und
wir da von diesem ganzen vor zwei wochen
natürlich auch schade es muss man gucken
den in österreich ist man mittlerweile
an dem punkt dass die entscheidung
getroffen werden muss wer kriegt noch
intensiv bett und wir nicht das wollen
wir nicht das wollen wir verhindern ich
glaube das will der allergrößte teil der
menschen im land nicht und und dass man
in der zeit in der wir jetzt sind
darüber nachdenkt die vier wochen
erstmal die wir uns verordnet haben
notfalls noch ein stück stärker zu
bremsen und zwar in einem bereich der
weder bildung noch wirtschaft
unmittelbar tangiert nämlich da wo wir
uns zum vergnügen treffen dass wir sagen
das geht dann eben nicht mit zehn
personen dann muss man mit einer kleinen
ja für all die maßnahmen dann zeige ich
auf die umfragen bekommen sie ganz viel
verständnis in der bevölkerung dann ganz
vorsichtig frage ob die menschen so viel
verständnis haben dass sie ständig ihre
ziele korrigieren müssen und ständig
nach zwei wochen wieder überarbeiten
glauben sie was meinen sie wir wissen
dass erst nach 14 tagen eine maßnahme
wirklich vom erfolg her gemessen und
beurteilt werden kann jetzt sind diese
14 tage um und es beginnt erst in der
nächsten woche beginnt erst die phase in
der wir wissen bewirkt der lok dann
etwas oder nicht und diese woche muss
man abwarten bevor man verschärfungen
diskutiert alles andere ist nicht ist
nicht das gesicht fliegt ist ja
nachvollziehbar wenn man dieses virus in
seiner ausbreitung mit wenig erfahrungen
nur wirklich immer nur im wochenrhythmus
also ist es wirklich nicht anders
möglich in der politik als immer nur von
woche zu woche sehen sie können um das
nochmal grundsätzlich zu bringen sie
können heute und können morgen nicht und
können auch noch nicht in der ganzen
nächsten woche den gastwirten sagen ob
sie am ersten dezember wieder ein
geschäft machen
oder nicht das können sie heute noch
nicht sagen also erst mal kann man sagen
wir sind auf einem immer noch
besorgniserregend hohen niveau dass die
aussicht eröffnet die schlechte aussicht
eröffnet dass man das anfang dezember
nicht unbedingt so abstellen kann wie
man sich das gewünscht hat zweiter punkt
ist ja es ist richtig dass man 14 tage
braucht und deswegen in der nächsten
woche gucken muss wie diese maßnahmen
vom anfang des monats wirken aber die
verschärfung wirkt ja auch erst nach 14
tagen das heißt wenn ich erst mal noch
eine woche warte und eine woche vor dem
dezember dann sage jetzt mache ich die
gruppen die sich treffen können kleiner
dann kann ich anfang dezember nicht
erzählen ich kann sehen ob das gewirkt
hat insofern ist das ist eine verzwickte
situation aber ich finde richtig dass
man sich das anguckt dass man sagt wir
sind auf einem sehr hohen niveau
es wirkt insofern schon als stabil hoch
ist und jetzt müssen wir trotzdem sagen
liebe leute lasst uns doch in einem
bereich der uns wirtschaftlich nicht
einschränkt weil das ist was
entscheidend dass wir wollen schließlich
am ende auch unsere jobs behalten und
wir wollen bildung aufrechterhalten dann
lasst uns doch in den sauren apfel
beißen und die gruppengröße mit der man
sich trifft noch ein stück verkleinern
und dann sehen wir am ende dass ich
weiterhin als sie wollen ja neue
obergrenze dass ich auch was in
österreich passiert ist eine neue
obergrenze für private treffen wie klein
sollte man die gruppe machen
also das wird sicher morgen diskutiert
besprechen wie wir miteinander auch auf
der seite der sozialdemokratischen
ministerpräsidenten und minister
präsidenten geführt haben auch mit der
kanzlerin ist zu sagen wir werden wohl
in richtung müssen dass ein haushalt
einen anderen treffen kann wenn er mit
nicht mehr als zwei personen an rückt
also dass wir nicht zehn personen
zusammen haben oder sogar je nach
institut zahl größe auf 25 oder mehr
kommen weil es ist klar die verbreitung
ist immer ausgegangen vom
zusammentreffen einer größeren gruppe
und noch mal wir sind im moment bei 10
das heißt wir würden weiter runter gehen
wenn wir jetzt eine fünfköpfige familie
haben die darf sich dann maximal noch
mit zwei anderen treffen
wer wäre eine möglichkeit alles andere
ist gegenstand der diskussion die es
morgen geben wird die fdp da stützen die
fdp erwartet dass wir jetzt mal zu einem
system kommen dass stringent ist wir
haben jetzt zu beginn des oder ende
oktober hieß es muss für einen monat
geschlossen werden jetzt hören wir schon
es soll neue verschärfungen geben obwohl
es keine zahlen gibt auf deren grundlage
man evaluieren kann ob die maßnahmen die
seit beginn des monats november greifen
überhaupt etwas bewirken aber innerhalb
dieses monats
ja aber wir haben noch keine november
hilfen ausbezahlt an die an die
gastronomen die warten auf ihr geld den
geht es schlecht wir diskutieren jetzt
schon wieder verlängerung von maßnahmen
ich finde wir müssen jetzt mal
evaluieren hat das was gebracht es ist
ja auch nicht überzeugen dass die runde
der bundeskanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten etwas beschließt und
dann zwei tage später kommen die ersten
ministerpräsidenten wir wollen aber
verschärfen
er fragt man sich warum kommt das vorher
nicht auf den tisch man verliert das
vertrauen in diese hunde zunehmend was
mich beim letzten mal auch gestört hat
war dass diese beschlüsse aus dem
bundeskanzleramt eine begründung
enthalten haben ich finde es ist an der
zeit den menschen zu erklären was man
hier macht und wir brauchen eine wir
hören von von der bundesregierung wir
werden wahrscheinlich noch bis in die
bis ins frühjahr hinein
der estrich unter altmaier hinterhalt
manier monate statt vier wochen aber
dann würde ich mir wünschen dass wir
nicht andere vorschläge bekommen dass
wir künftig schulunterricht in
restaurants und knall kommen wir da
können wir noch hin in der diskussion
ich will noch einen punkt um das ganze
zu verstehen weil das gleicht ja
wirklich in unser aller alltag ein sie
sagen jetzt sie würden auch dafür
plädieren voraussichtlich die kontakte
die privaten kontakte noch weiter
einzuschränken von 10 weiter runter zu
gehen
ganz konkret was würde das für
weihnachten bedeuten also das heißt ober
und opa schon mal auf jeden fall nicht
einladen also fremde lädt man ja
meistens dann eher nicht allen sondern
im engsten familienkreis aber der ist
dann wo endet er dann der engste familie
zunächst mal wir reden über den zeitraum
vor vier wochen die wir besprochen haben
bei dem wir glauben dass wir dann
jedenfalls auch am ende dieses zeitraums
anfang dezember sehen können sind wir
wirklich ein stück runter
das ziel bleibt und das war am anfang
schon das ziel warum es im november
gemacht haben das ist immer ein monat in
dem es umsatzmäßig er es auf einem
niedrigen niveau ist zu sagen wir wollen
weihnachten und auch die
vorweihnachtszeit natürlich mit so viel
möglichkeiten eingeschränkten
möglichkeiten der freiheit und der
fröhlichkeit feiern lassen das geht gilt
auch für das jahresende in richtung
silvester so muss klar sein muss was
herr bissingen angesprochen hat ist ja
die hilfen müssen mal langsam ausgezahlt
wird
da merkt man gleich auf den auf den
wirtschaftsminister und der zweite punkt
ist sollte man es verlängern über den
november hinaus
dann wird auch die hilfe wieder
gefordert sein für den dezember oder für
den anfang dezember also sollten wir
einmal ganz kurz fest dass dieser
einstiegs runde
sie wollen evaluieren ihren weil wir die
zahlen eben noch nicht haben
die die locker und wirkung zeigen
trotzdem weiter bei uns bei ihnen auch
ich ganz klar aus sie gehen eher von
verschärfungen aus er davon aus dass man
vor weihnachten bis weihnachten noch mal
nachsteuern muss und darüber habe ich
vor wenigen stunden auch mit dem
ministerpräsidenten nordrhein westfalens
gesprochen mit armin laschet guten abend
zeigt dieser lockdown bisher seine
erhoffte wirkung
also er gilt seit dem zweiten november
das sind jetzt gerade einmal 13 tage
also noch keine kompletten zwei wochen
wir sehen dass sich das exponentielle
wachstum gebrochen hat so sind wohl die
daten auch des heutigen tages aber wir
können noch nicht sehe dass es anlass
zur entspannung gibt und deshalb muss
man die nächsten tage genau beobachten
zehn bis 14 tage ist ja die
inkubationszeit ich habe den eindruck
vieles was man jetzt erkennt an
verlangsamung ist schon eine reaktion
der menschen bevor der teil lockdown
beschlossen wurde
sie haben reagiert auf die öfen
die diskussion und sind vorsichtiger
geworden und ich glaube das ist vor
allem das entscheidende dass die
menschen mitmachen aber genau deswegen
frage ich an welchen zahlen bemisst man
das denn man wollte ja nach zwei wochen
das ist dann eben morgen den strich
drunter ziehen und wollte sagen okay
jetzt können wir zur halbzeit dieses
november schon einmal sehen bringt das
alles was was man machen ist das
möglicherweise zu viel oder ist es zu
wenig müssen wir die maßnahmen anpassen
das heißt können sie das überhaupt nach
zwei wochen haben sie alle daten alle
zahlen die sie brauchen um das morgen zu
entscheiden um strich drunter zu ziehen
also wir haben alle zahlen alle daten
aber dieser morgige termin war einfach
als zwischenbilanz termine gedacht da
kann man noch keine entscheidungen
darüber fällen wie das endgültig nach
dem 30 november weitergeht dazu muss man
noch weitere zahlen abwarten abwarten
eines ist jedenfalls klar es wird ab
morgen keine weiteren öffnungen geben so
viel kann man heute schon sagen aber
alles weitere glaube ich sollte man dann
in einer zeitnahen weiteren
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz besprechen
wenn wir eine etwas bessere datenbasis
über einen längeren zeitraum haben aber
das versprechen war doch haltet mal gut
für vier wochen erstmal durch das war
immer wieder betont worden gilt erstmal
nur für vier wochen wenn ihr euch an die
regeln halten erhaltet dann wird das
schon wirkung zeigen nach diesen vier
wochen und dann werden wir neu
verhandeln gilt dieses versprechen noch
jetzt haben wir erstmal 13 tage und
keine vier wochen
und deshalb werden wir morgen bilanz
ziehen wo wir stehen es ist halbzeit und
entscheiden wie es weitergeht kann man
dann erst zu einem späteren zeitpunkt
sie sagen jetzt sie schließen
lockerungen erstmal ausstand heute
schließen sie den verschärfungen ganz
offenbar überhaupt nicht mehr aus diesen
sound gab es ja vor zwei wochen nicht
schließen sie das jetzt nicht mehr aus
es geht ja nicht darum ob man nun auf
die frage die sich stellen ob man
ausschließt oder nicht ausschließt dann
irgendetwas sagt aus dem man dann wieder
zurück
folgerungen ziehen könnte morgen treffen
wir uns morgen beraten wir die lage dann
geht es übrigens auch um mehr da geht es
darum die impfstrategie und vieles
andere mehr
und nur von den zahlen die wir heute
haben kann man nicht sagen
wir sind schneller fertig wir brauchen
nicht vier wochen warten nach zwei
wochen kann man alles wieder öffnen
das ist morgen nicht das ergebnis
ansonsten würde ich uns allen empfehlen
jetzt auch hier ruhig und besonnen zu
handeln wirklich die entwicklung
abzuwarten und erst dann weitere
entscheidungen zu fällen dazu ist es
morgen zu früh das heißt doch einmal
nachgefragt um das klar zu haben in dem
ministerpräsident sie wollten nach den
zwei wochen strich drunter ziehen
halbzeit november ein mal gucken was hat
das bisher gebracht und wollten dann die
maßnahmen gegebenenfalls anpassen morgen
passiert keine anpassung sie warten
einfach weiter ab da wir noch mitten in
den gesprächen sind an diesem heutigen
tag am morgigen morgen bevor wir dann um
14 uhr in einer telefonschalte mit der
bundeskanzlerin zusammen kommen kann man
das zum jetzigen zeitpunkt noch nicht
abschließend sagen
ich empfehle uns ruhig und besonnen hier
zu reagieren die zahlen genau zu
analysieren und sich zu einem zeitnahen
zeitpunkt wieder zu treffen um dann über
die zeit nach dem 30 november zu braten
ich kenne keine familie verlasse die
nicht weihnachten planen möchte die
nicht wissen möchte wie das aussieht zu
weihnachten die natürlich auch gedanken
hat wie das weihnachtsshopping aussieht
die möglicherweise auch weiter denkt an
silvester auch an geburtstage und so
weiter die vor allen dingen ihren alltag
im moment ein bisschen längerfristig mal
organisieren möchte als immer nur für
zwei wochen
warum muten sie der bevölkerung dass
immer alles so scheibchenweise nur zu
also ich glaube nicht dass die
bevölkerung beweist dass auch nicht die
politik die ministerpräsident die
bundeskanzlerin der
bundesgesundheitsminister mutet menschen
etwas zu sondern des virus das virus ist
unberechenbar und das merken wir tag für
tag und niemand kann jetzt sagen 'bitte
politik erklären wir mal ob ich
weihnachtsferien
osterferien ob ich im nächsten jahr
heiraten kann man kann es
realistischerweise nicht beantworten wir
bewegen uns in einer weltweit
einzigartigen situation sowohl
historisch haben wir so etwas noch nicht
erlebt als auch im vergleich zu anderen
ländern und sie sehen was österreich
gerade macht die hatten im sommer
weitgehend alles geöffnet ergreifen
jetzt drastische maßnahmen bis mitte
dezember befristet in der hoffnung dann
ein ruhigeres weihnachtsfest zu feiern
ob das funktioniert weiß niemand wir
haben andere länder in europa erlebt in
die im sommer drastische maßnahmen hat
spanien zum beispiel und trotzdem
explodieren jetzt die infektionszahlen
also es gibt kein patentrezept mit dem
man sagen könnte wenn man besonders
streng ist sinken die zahlen
wir wissen nur jede kontakt beschränkung
senkt die zahlen und wenn wir da
erfolgreich sind dann können wir
vielleicht in zwei drei vier wochen also
anfang dezember leichter über
weihnachten reden als wenn es zum
heutigen tag können
aber wann wünsche mir genauso wie sie
und wie ihre leser und zuschauer ein
schönes weihnachtsfest
aber ob das gelingt liegt an uns allen
als der gastwirt erfährt heute noch
nicht was im dezember läuft und er wird
auch ganz kurzfristig überhaupt erst
wissen ob er im dezember bei 0 steht
oder ob er irgendwelche einnahmen hat
das beides erfährt er nicht morgen und
ich heute uns genauso gilt das für die
millionen schüler und schülerinnen und
für alle lehrer auch bei ihnen im land
in nordrhein westfalen für die können
sie tag heute auch nicht sagen sind die
schulen im dezember offen oder
geschlossen
das kann man auch noch nicht beantworten
auch das hängt vom infektionsgeschehen
api gibt es aber den großen konsens
aller 16 länder präsenzunterricht zu
erhalten
man kann in einzelfällen auch auf
wechselnde systeme weg also umsteigen in
denen auch unterricht zu hause erteilt
wird aber der ist immer nur zweitbeste
lösung viele kinder haben niemanden zu
hause der ihnen helfen kann
beim unterricht sie haben vielleicht
nicht mal ein endgerät wie sie in einer
beengten 2 3 zimmerwohnungen vielleicht
mit 2 3 geschwisterkinder und
bildungschancen heißt bildungschancen
für alle und deshalb ist das ziel aller
kultusminister auch übrigens alle
ministerpräsidenten so lange wie möglich
so sicher wie möglich präsenzunterricht
zu erhalten und daran arbeiten wir unter
hochdruck klar das ziel ist klar dass es
von ihnen klar benannt die frage ist wie
es dann in der praxis aussieht auch
darauf warten einfach millionen menschen
in deutschland suchen nach diesen
antworten weil die natürlich ständig
ihren alltag um organisieren müssen und
das klappt einfach manchmal nicht so
kurzfristig wie haben einmal geschaut
wie viele von den wichtigsten
entscheidungen der politik
schulpflichtige kinder haben die idee in
dieser ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit
der kanzlerin sind im moment zwei liegt
das möglicherweise daran dass man diese
alltags entscheidung so lange auf die
lange bank schickt da ist man selber
vielleicht ganz manchmal bis hin zu
wenig bezug zu diesem alltag hat was
würden sie jetzt lange bank nennen wenn
man den familien erst zwei wochen vorher
sagt wie es im dezember aussieht wie die
ihren alltag ihren schulalltag
organisieren müssen
ob ein elternteil zu hause bleiben muss
oder nicht ja wenn das so wäre dann
müsste man ihnen das sagen wenn man es
müsste müsste man ihnen das sagen ich
glaube nicht dass es an der frage von
der frage abhängig ob sie kinder haben
oder nicht sie können schon glauben dass
jemand der auch etwas ältere kinder hat
schon noch weiß was sich in familien
bewegt er ist ständig auch ich selbst
mit vielen familien in kontakt aber
diesen familien ehrlicherweise muss man
sagen wir tun alles dass der
präsenzunterricht bleibt und warum soll
ich jetzt die eltern verunsichern dass
möglicherweise im dezember wenn
möglicherweise die zahlen sich
anders entwickeln wenn möglicherweise es
dann zu einer schulschließung kommen
könnte was wir dann machen
meinen sie nicht dass würde eltern mehr
verunsichern als dass unser ziel klar
ist und wir alles dafür tun dass
präsenzunterricht für eltern garantiert
ist in 95 prozent aller schulen in
nordrhein westfalen ist funktioniert der
unterricht sehr gut und ich glaube das
ist das anders an dem eltern uns messen
kannst du gut bildung sicher
organisieren
stand heute es gelingt also armin
laschet sagt jetzt wird erstmal noch gar
nichts entschieden wir warten noch mal
ab aber wir wollen auch noch nicht so
recht verschärfen er wissen
doch einmal nachgefragt weil es wie
jedem gespräch wirklich ein bisschen
geärgert hat dass wir nicht mehr
sicherheit bekommen ist es wirklich
nicht anders möglich im moment in dieser
lage wir wissen alle wie schwierig das
ist für das ganze land was für eine
herausforderung ist dass wir alle dass
wir uns nicht ganz genau kennen völlig
klar völlig richtig trotzdem ist es
nicht möglich den familien ein bisschen
mehr stringenz ein bisschen mehr
kontinuität im alltag zu geben also im
zu jetzigen zeitpunkt läuft ein
experiment auf das sich die
ministerpräsidentin ministerpräsidenten
mit der bundeskanzlerin verständigt
haben das ist ein versuch wir können
nach zwei wochen nach dem was die
virologen sagen nicht wissen ob dieser
versuch erfolgreich ist oder nicht und
deswegen ist es nachvollziehbar dass
herr laschet sagt wir können heute nicht
die antwort geben wie geht es genau
dezember mit der schule weiter ist aber
auch richtig dass man sich in der
situation nicht hinstellen kann und
sagen kann wir brauchen jetzt noch
zusätzliche verschärfungen da und da und
dort
es muss in beide richtungen evaluiert
werden ja und vor dem hintergrund
verstehe ich nicht warum man jetzt schon
wieder diskutiert dass man zusätzliche
masken pflichten für die grundschulen
braucht dass man überlegt wie man im
privaten bereich weitere restriktionen
antwort also lasse sich zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt erst mal aber ich möchte gerne
sein ich möchte gerne dass diese dinge
nicht ständig ins blaue hinein gefordert
werden sondern dass wir irgendwann auf
und system kommen wo wir erklären können
warum machen wir was es ist nicht es ist
nicht klar ob die schließung der
gastronomie einen beitrag zum
zurückdrängen dieses wie dieser virus
pandemie leisten kann aber den lassen
wir uns die sekunde bei der gastronomie
bleiben also das gehört ja zu den
wesentlichen maßnahmen dazu
freizeiteinrichtungen die gastronomie
dicht bordelle dicht und so weiter und
so fort
gehen sie davon aus zeitpunkt jetzt dass
irgendeine dieser maßnahmen gelockert
werden könnte
zum ersten zwölften die absicht diesen
monat zu nutzen um möglichst wieder
lockern zu können bleibt bestehen aber
wir sehen das was herr laschet auch
gesagt hat das niveau ob wir sind jetzt
wir haben die den anstieg gebrochen aber
auf hohem niveau fährt dieser zug weiter
mit 20 denn von den zielen die kollegen
kennen weil die helfen habe ich an der
stelle gar jetzt geht's darum deswegen
haben wir immer gesagt wir wollen noch
zwei dinge sicher stellen wir wollen das
thema bildung nicht antasten weil da
fällt die gesellschaft am ehesten
auseinander
auch da kann ich nur sagen hat recht
wenn er sagt das leben nicht alle in
einem haus mit soviel zimmern dann hat
jeder seinen computer sondern da müssen
wir rücksicht darauf nehmen und deswegen
ist der präsenzunterricht das richtige
zweiter punkt ist man kann das nicht
das kann man nicht über einen kamm
scheren für das ganze bundesgebiet es
gibt schulen oder länder in denen ist in
der schule im prinzip kein problem
vorhanden es gibt städte sprechen
wirklich gleich aber die schulen aber
die die frage zielte auf das tier wollen
das problem ist ja ich wollte nur sagen
das zweite ist ja dass die wirtschaft so
weit wie möglich unangetastet bleiben
sollte jetzt haben wir ein problem das
sind teil der wirtschaft sein geld mit
dem vergnügen mit dem privatleben der
menschen verdient das ist eine
überraschende erkenntnis aber das ist
ein ausschnitt um den wir uns ja auch
ganz besonders und kümmert haben indem
er jetzt gesagt haben es gibt diese
november hilfe 75% des ausfalls der der
umsätze werden erstattet deswegen habe
ich eben auch gesagt wenn das länger
geht muss auch klar sein es muss eine
verlässlichkeit da sein das dann nicht
am ende november ende ist wir müssen
aber noch eine woche vielleicht länger
zu halten also die deswegen ist auch
jeder deswegen ist das doch auch das
heißt ja nochmal ganz kurzer zeit
verlässlichkeit heißt staatshilfen so
lange wieder locker und bestehen das
muss gelten und das zweite ist dass man
sich natürlich immer überlegt ich möchte
ihnen so kurz halten wie nur möglich
also was haben wir denn davon wenn wir
sagen wir planen langfristig
und sagen mal also zwei monate muss nur
noch zu behalten wir möchten am liebsten
überall heitmeier wie wir gerade schon
gehört haben
er sagt ja heute noch das kann auch bis
ins frühe reingehen das heißt vier
monate statt vier wochen dann wird es
schon ganz schön eng mit der staat sich
wie gesagt dafür bis zum frühjahr
praktisch diese november bringen so
aussehen
er hat gesagt dass man bis zum frühjahr
mit einschränkungen rechnen muss ich
würde mal sagen
das gilt mindestens da sind diese corona
bedingungen von denen auch die kanzlerin
gesprochen hat aber wichtig um konkret
sind also ja ja das bedeutet restaurants
doch wieder zu eröffnen da habe ich
jetzt in letzter zeit niemand mehr alle
ich habe dann halt halt meint jedenfalls
habe ich noch nie einen aus dem inneren
kreis derer die da entscheiden gehört
der gesagt hat dass kann auch sein dass
die castor 14 monate zu lassen
es geht jetzt um die frage schaffen wir
das bis ende des monats oder müssen wir
diese strecke ein stück aus denen mit
der sicherheit die dann auch zu
gewährleisten ist aber immer mit dem
ziel auch aus diesen wirtschaftlichen
gründen auch aus haushaltsgründen diese
strecke so kurz wie möglich das sehr
interessant also wie gesagt sie sind ja
zahlen freaks sie kommen aus dem
finanzbereich sie gehen jetzt nicht
davon aus dass wenn wir über vier monate
mittlerweile sprechen wie er altmaier
dass wir dann davon ausgehen dass wir
diese form von restaurant schließung
überhaupt über so einen langen zeitraum
finanzieren können das wäre aus meiner
sicht etwas
es ist ja nicht bloß die frage ob ein
restaurant den umsatzausfall ersetzt
bekommt sondern da hängt ja enorm viel
dran und ich muss sagen wir wollen das
leben und zwar nicht bloß das
gastronomische sondern auch das
kulturelle die solo solo selbstständigen
die sozusagen in der zweiten reihe führt
zum teil diese institutionen und für die
wirtschaft arbeiten das kann man nicht
einfach ein halbes jahr zum erliegen
bringen und das ist aber doch der grund
warum man schrittweise vorgehen muss
eben mal wieder über weise wir leben
auch dann von noch mal ein oder zwei
wochen und jetzt nicht noch mal mona
wäre meine einschätzung im augenblick
ich bin nicht derjenige der morgen am
tisch diese diskussion führt ich habe
den respekt vor den
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten dass sie ihre länder
jeweils am besten kennen
ich glaube dass viel zu oft in berlin
der eindruck erweckt wird wir machen
hier mal das klingt immer gut wir machen
eine lösung die gilt für alle und dann
werden regionen getroffen die anders
leben könnten im augen also die
gespräche auf mecklenburg vorpommern
anderem die ministerpräsidenten haben
oder eben auch in rheinland pfalz mit
malu dreyer schauen wir einmal auf das
was der ministerpräsident bayern zu uns
heute gesagt hat auch mit ihm habe ich
über das thema mögliche verschärfung
heute sprechen können schönen guten
abend morgen wir gucken alle auf diesen
halbzeit termin morgen keine
entscheidung keine lockerung aber auch
offenbar erstmal keine verschärfung und
wann es dann der nächste termin auf den
wir alle schielen müssen ja in der woche
glaube ich will man mehr wissen
aber diese woche müssen wir ehrlich
gesagt auch nutzen um an einigen stellen
nachzuarbeiten
wir können jetzt einfach nur sagen nach
vier wochen ist entweder wieder alles
gut oder alles ist schlimm
das wäre auch zu einfach sondern wir
müssen uns zb mit dem thema schule noch
mal intensiv beschäftigen
wir haben wir das ziel schule und kita
offen zu halten wir spüren aber auch
dort wachsende zahl von infektionen und
ich sags mal so die temperatur auch bei
den einzelnen beteiligten in der
schulfamilie die steigt auch also eltern
gegen lehrer lehrer gegen eltern
schulbehörden die sich überfordert
fühlen und viel diskussion also auch da
müssen wir noch mal nacharbeiten in
welchen bereichen wir beispielsweise
sagen wenn man denn irgendwann zu einem
wechsel unterricht käme beispielsweise
für die älteren schüler wie kann das
stattfinden wie können wir
beispielsweise das digitale format noch
einmal optimal gestalten
das müssen wir im laufe der nächsten
woche dann auch besprechen denn ich
werbe sehr dafür
gerade in der schule dass wir am ende da
sehr einheitliche corona regeln für ganz
deutschland haben und es nicht im klein
klein verlieren
das heißt da werden sie ganz aktiv aus
bayern heraus für eine gewisse
verschärfung für ältere schüler richtig
also zunächst mal habe ich dafür dass
wir die masken pflicht überall einführen
die maske ist wer wirklich schule länger
offen lassen will der muss auch
präventiv wirken und da ist die maske
ganz entscheiden auch in der grundschule
wir haben nochmal empfehlungen von der
leopoldina bekommen jetzt am wochenende
die sagen eindeutig dass die maske
erstens ein ganz wichtiges instrument
ist und zweitens sie weisen auf die
gefahr an dass die schule auch ein
infektionsherd ist wenn zum glück auch
die symptome
weniger sichtbar sind als bei älteren
können sie gerade bei vielen schülern
auch da sein also müssen wir das jetzt
evaluieren in der woche und dann
überlegen wenn wir dazu kommen wir haben
jetzt schon die situation dass schulen
oder auch schulklassen in quarantäne
gehen müssen die wir trotzdem den
unterricht gut managen können wir vor
allem eines schaffen
für mich ist das oberste ziel nicht nur
einfach schule offen zu halten sondern
die qualität zu erhalten
wir dürfen nicht dauernd leistungsdruck
in der schule habe ich höre so vielfach
von eltern berichtet dass manche lehrer
meinen jetzt können wir noch mal schnell
ein paar prüfen und schreiben wir wissen
nicht wie lange die schule offen ist
diese art von leistungsdruck führt am
ende zu einem unfairen schuljahr wir
brauchen ein faires schuljahr auch wenn
es das gebe ich zu wägen kroner kein
normales sein wird für viele bereiche
gab es relativ klare regeln für einen
bereich eben für die schulen gibt es das
bis heute nicht wirklich und der
eindruck entsteht so ein bisschen nach
das feld dann doch am ende ein bisschen
runter
liegt das auch daran dass sehr viele der
ministerpräsidenten sehr sehr viele der
entscheider und sie eben nicht
schulpflichtige kinder im moment keine
also keine schulpflichtigen kinder haben
ich weiß es woanders ist ich weiß und es
gibt tatsächlich zu dass bei uns zu
hause das thema schule fast täglich
besprochen wird meine frau ist seit
vielen jahren in allen bereichen aktiv
in der schule
sie berichtet wir von den gesprächen mit
den lehrerinnen und lehrern aber auch
von den kindern hört man das oder den
freunden der kinder wie die jeweilige
situation an den schulen ist ich selber
beschäftige mich echt fast die ganze
zeit damit wir haben schon mehrere
schulgipfel gehabt weil mich das auch
wirklich umtreibt wie sie die wir machen
es perfekt dass alle möglichen branchen
geld bekommen die jetzt ein auswahl an
ist auch gut so muss man allerdings
andere bisher nachbessern aber das ist
auf dem richtigen weg nur bei der schule
habe ich außer den eindruck dass es für
viele sehr weit weg ist und deswegen das
ist für mich eines der absolut
wichtigsten themen
die jungen leute haben doch sowieso
einen schlimmen form ein schlimmes jahr
gehabt ich denke an meine jugend was da
alles möglich war
draußen sein freizeit gestalten mit
freunden mit freunden das alles geht
jetzt nicht noch nie war eine junge
generation seit dem zweiten weltkrieg so
eingeschränkt wird und es sind müssen
wir alles daran tun das in der schule
für die schule und für diese jungen
leute eine echte perspektive bleibt und
sie nicht hinten runterfallen
der schule muss man auch mal
nacharbeiten jetzt auch schon in dieser
woche weil man merkt das reicht einfach
nicht verschwinden dauert wieder schüler
lehrer aus der schule gehen in
quarantäne
die organisation ist vielerorts nicht
mehr aufrechtzuerhalten was muss
nachgearbeitet werden aus sicht der spd
arbeiter bei uns sicher nicht dass man
das was für die am schwersten
betroffenen gemeinden bayerns nötig ist
jetzt auf die gesamte bundesrepublik aus
denen die schulen dicht heißt ich wüsste
gerne mal was herr söder sagen würde
wenn er ministerpräsident eines landes
wäre das sehr gering betroffen ist und
die anderen fordern würden dass er in
seinen schulen bitte die selben regeln
anlegt wie die wie diejenigen die stars
sollen einheitliche regeln
bundeseinheitlich man kann doch nicht
das was in garmisch partenkirchen und
berchtesgadener land im augenblick nötig
ist eins zu eins auf mecklenburg
vorpommern übertragen oder
schleswig-holstein ich will es gar nicht
von der frage der farbe in den in den
ländern reden sondern die schüler müssen
doch die möglichkeit wir müssen noch die
möglichkeiten suchen so viel freiraum
wie möglich zu gewähren herr söder hat
gesagt noch nie ist eine generation so
stark getroffen worden
dann muss ich sie doch nicht hin weder
ist teilen sie das ja natürlich wir
erleben doch gerade bei jungen leuten
wie stark diese sozialen kontakte die
eingeschränkten sozialen kontakte wirken
und deswegen haben wir da auch natürlich
das problem dass es hier nun wieder auch
sag jetzt mal missachtung dieser regeln
gibt und jeder der mal jungen war das
glaube ich komme alle von uns behaupten
weiß wie man damit umgeht
und trotzdem muss man an diese ich
glaube dass die jungs eben heute
besonders verantwortungsvoll auch ist
also in allen gesprächen die die ich
führe kann ich das nur sagen und ich
habe zwar keine schulpflichtigen kinder
mehr aber ich habe immerhin vier
mittlerweile erwachsene kinder und hab
da eine sehr lebendige erinnerung aber
diese diese frage ist doch wirklich wie
schaffen den rat in dem bereich so viel
freiraum wie möglich und halten uns aber
auch an die erkenntnisse der
wissenschaft dass wir wissen schulen
sind nicht einfach immun das ist
vollkommen klar also eine einheitliche
regeln bundeseinheitliche regeln lässt
sieht hier vor allen dingen auf die
quarantäne regelungen nicht darauf dass
man jetzt bundeseinheitlich die schulen
dicht macht sondern bundes
quarantäne regen das sich zum beispiel
jeder weiß was gilt das lesen sie ab ich
weiß zum beispiel aus nordrhein
westfälischen kommunen dass es einzelne
städte gibt in denen es richtige
probleme gibt und die müssen
möglichkeiten haben auch besondere
maßnahmen zu ergreifen aber es gibt
ganze länder die dieses problem weniger
haben und die kann ich nicht einfach
mitreißen und sagen das muss jetzt für
alle wollten sie nicht wir erweitern
ganz kurz unsere runde nochmal um
susanne eisenmann die kultusministerin
baden württemberg sonst zugeschaltet und
wir haben gerade den ministerpräsidenten
schönen guten abend frau eisenmann
gehört der gesagt hat aber den schulen
müssen wir noch mal nacharbeiten da
meinte er also auch sie als
kultusministerin wo fühlen sie sich am
gewissen gepackt oder wo geht es bei
ihnen noch was nach zu arbeiten in
dieser woche damit verlaub ich kann die
argumentation ich hab's ja eben gehört
von ministerpräsident sicherlich ganz
nachvollziehen und die frage ob ich
jetzt kinder habe oder sie zugang zu
diesen themen habe würde ich dringend
raten sich vor allem an fakten zur
organisation zu orientieren oder kann
man klar sagen wo kann in den donnerstag
waren in deutschland 100 und sechs
schulen wegen corona komplett
geschlossen
106 schulen und über 41.000
schulen sind nicht doch hotspot und ich
kann nur dringend dafür werben dass
betreuung gilt auch für kitas und
bildung mit pandemie natürlich unter
besonderen bedingungen in einklang
gebracht werden muss und deshalb kann
ich nicht erkennen dass wir bei den
schulen nachjustieren müssen
das heißt ja nicht unbedingt nur frau
eisenmann verschärfen das bedeutet ja
auch klarheit also ich habe es hier in
berlin erlebt das ist halt einfach auch
innerhalb berlins so unterschiedlich
gehandhabt wird wann wird eine ganze
klasse rausgeschickt erstmal ist
überhaupt das gesundheitsamt zu
erreichen um diese regelungen zu treffen
dann auf lokaler ebene aber das noch mal
andere frage geht dann die ganze klasse
raus oder werden nur einzelne schüler
aus dem einzelnen kurs nur rausgeschickt
für viel lange eigentlich wird die ganze
schule möglicherweise dicht gemacht das
heißt da gibt es einen großen bedarf in
den familien zu wissen wie überhaupt die
regelungen sind mein eindruck ist schon
da gibt es noch ein bisschen was nach zu
arbeiten
aber das ist so nicht es wie verlaub für
den wir reden gerade ging es um masken
krieg den grundschulen es ging um
rollierendes wechselsystem für ältere
schülerinnen und schüler da kann ich nur
dringend raten märz april war das beste
beispiel dafür aus den erfahrungen
müssen wir lernen dass bildung auch
kranke mit zeiten und zwar im
präsenzunterricht angeboten werden muss
wir haben nicht nur schülerinnen und
schüler die aus einem soliden
bildungsbürgertum kommen und die
bekleidung stattfindet so dass wir noch
viele schülerinnen und schüler die in
schwierigen familiären verhältnissen
sind wo schule und kita
auch struktur geben und daraus müssen
wir lernen und deshalb gibt andere
methoden andere ansätze also das sind ja
die themen dass die gesundheitsämter
einheitliche quarantäne vorgaben machen
gesundheitsämter parteilich ihre
einschätzung ich habe für mich ja nicht
die diskussion die momentan läuft das
ist etwas was man umsetzen kann und
umsetzen muss aber momentan geht es ja
darum was muss ich bei den schulen noch
machen weil die werte steigen da kann
ich nur sagen ich kann das beispiel
baden württemberg sagen da war es so
dass in den letzten vier wochen
die anzahl der infizierten der korona
infizierten bei kinder und jugendlichen
unter 19 jahren die es in den letzten
vier wochen rund 16 auf 13 gesunken
das ist nicht hotspot das ist nicht das
hauptproblem und deshalb meine dringende
bitte auch die ministerpräsident
ministerpräsident die schulen müssen im
präsenzunterricht bleiben alles andere
wäre eine katastrophe und wäre aus
meiner sicht auch eine fehlentscheidung
die lehrer selbst sage ich mal so
flapsig jammern ja auch und sagen sie
sind so eigentlich die letzten an der
korona front die da mehr oder weniger
ungeschützte arbeiten müssen
teilen sie diese jammer reihen
anführungsstrichen freisen man also
erstmal sind viele wo ich auch sehr
dankbar sind die arbeiten ob es
klägerinnen und kläger sind ärztinnen
und ärzte oder nehmen sie auch
betreuerinnen und verkäufer im ganzen
handel
wir haben viele die aktiv arbeit und ich
aber auch großen respekt bei unserer
lehrerinnen und lehrer aber auch da gilt
deutschlandweit sind momentan rund
13.000 lehrerinnen und lehrer nicht mal
1,5 prozent in quarantäne
nicht mal 1,5 prozent und ich glaube
dass die hygienemaßnahmen wie wir
abgestimmt haben bundesweit zwischen den
ländern durchaus 3 man muss es im blick
behalten habe meine herzliche bitte ist
die einfache lösung zu sagen erstens wir
machen wechselsystem oder wir schließen
gar schule ist die falsche entscheidung
beides angesichts der infektionszahlen
nicht unser zentrales problem ist und
damit ist nicht gelingt corona weiter
einzudämmen was wir müssen sondern dass
eltern lehrer schüler schülerinnen und
schüler was sie verunsichert und ich
finde es auch schade sage ich in aller
offenheit dass immer wenn man darüber
spricht was man als nächstes macht
lieber von den schulen gesprochen wird
und es in die schulen und auch in die
elternschaft in eine große unruhe
hervorruft und deshalb die zahlen sagen
deutlich wir müssen schützen wir müssen
natürlich die infektionszahlen
zurückbringen aber die schulen und die
kitas sind nicht diejenigen von denen es
ausgeht dass belag belegen die zahlen
deutschlandweit meine herzliche bitte
ist dieses nicht aus dem blick zu
flammende appell ist angekommen freut
man das müssen wir noch mal ganz kurz
hier auch in der runde diskutieren das
wechselt system das dann ja vor allen
dingen ältere schüler treffen würde er
wissen wie sehen sie das auch strikter
gegner wir haben jetzt kennengelernt
herr söder befürwortet dass er herr
laschet lernt lehnte er ab frau
eisenbahn ist strikt strikt strikt
dagegen will das auf keinen fall wie sie
die fdp das ist nicht einmal bayern
schlechtere zahlen als andere
bundesländer
das muss herr söder erklären wir haben
die situation dass wir ein recht auf
bildung haben und das was im frühjahr
passiert ist die schulschließungen auch
das wechselsystem hat massive
auswirkungen auf die schülerinnen und
schüler gehabt keiner kann sich wünschen
dass man so etwas wiederholt und schon
gar nicht ohne not und wir haben jetzt
vor wenigen wochen gehört dass es keine
infektion style gibt an den grundschulen
jetzt hören wir plötzlich wir brauchen
dort dringend eine maske nicht
das hat er auch keine stringenz ich
empfehle drehte sich das eigentlich also
da geht es ja auch um
alltagstauglichkeit ja es muss doch eine
schöne geld das momentan ist es in der
grundschule lässt es sich durch haltende
auf der kauft in der grundschule auf dem
schulhof mit maske zu tragen frau
eisenmann halten sie das für realistisch
also wir haben in baden württemberg seit
wochen bereits die masten kriegt auch im
unterricht ab klasse 5 ich halte von den
kitas und grundschulen mit masken kriegt
gar nicht weil ich auch ein stück weit
in der argumentation für schritt halten
wir haben studien wissenschaftliche
studien eigene beispielsweise der
universität heidelberg aus island aus
den niederlanden die besagen bis zehn
jahre tragen kinder vergleichsweise
wenig zum infektionsgeschehen bei uns
mal umgangssprachlich zu sagen dann ist
aber widersinnig zu sagen jetzt mache
ich in den grundschulen masken pflicht
wenn ich eigentlich weiß warum auch
immer das kind ein vergleichsweise wenig
dazu beitragen das ist aktionismus
möchte ich in aller deutlichkeit sagen
bei uns können in der grundschule die
lehrerinnen lehrer freiwillig maske
tragen aber den masten pflicht in den
grundschulen leuchtet mir schlicht nicht
ein und zimmer mal ehrlich maske im
quoten bericht wird bei uns ab klasse 5
ist eine herausforderung für alle
beteiligten und in den grundschulen ist
dass der doppel der ausladung weil die
kinder auch noch ziemlich jung und
ziemlich klein sind aber wenn ich den
biss
wirtschaftlichen studien glaube was wir
tun dann sind bis zehn jahre gar nicht
der entscheidende punkt und deshalb kann
noch die masten pflicht im unterricht
mir nicht erklären
außer mit aktionismus die grundschulen
sind für mich wahrlich nicht das thema
das man angehen sollte und deshalb wenig
persönlich dass die grundschulen ab wir
singen ich hatte sie unterbrochen gerade
nein das ist gut nachvollziehbaren ich
finde es auch dringend erforderlich dass
wir den menschen faktenbasierte regeln
geben und nicht irgendwie was aus dem
gefühl heraus ich habe den eindruck das
sind einige unterwegs die gefallen sich
darin im abstand von ein zwei wochen
ständig was neues zu sein sie hat
sondern dann damit ja beispielsweise ich
finde das ist der hat ja auch damals
dieses berges verbot wenn er ins
gespräch gebracht und hat sich
ordentlich damit blamiert ich finde das
kann so nicht gehen wir brauchen die
menschen die müssen aus überzeugung
mitmachen eltern müssen das unterstützen
die schüler müssen davon überzeugt
werden dass das richtig ist was wir von
ihnen fordern dann können wir aber nicht
und hat freie mann völlig recht gegen
wissenschaftliche fakten argumentieren
und ich will auch noch mal was zu diesem
lockdown sagen wenn wir nach einer woche
feststellen dass dieser lockdown nichts
gebracht hat dann kann man ja nicht
sagen dann muss er zwangsläufig
verschärft werden sondern dann muss man
sich die frage stellen ob wir
möglicherweise bereiche geschlossen
haben die gar keine infektions treiber
waren auch in diese richtung muss
gedacht werden
wir müssen mal das freie denken wieder
einschalten in deutschland und nicht in
solchen aktionismus betreiben
ich habe auch ein interesse dass sie
würden dann sogar erwägen das bedeutet
das ja wenn wenn rauskommt er hat keine
wirkung erzielt das heißt wir haben die
falschen spots geschlossenen restaurants
beispielsweise hätten nicht geschlossen
werden müssen das heißt sie würden dann
erwägen die restaurants erst recht
wieder also das lka hat uns gesagt es
gibt also keine hinweise darauf dass die
restaurants infektions treiber sind da
hat man gesagt wir wissen aber nicht
genau ob es vielleicht doch der fall ist
klar wir machen dann eine chance
verstanden aber wenn wir aber
geschlossen hat und die infektionen
gehen nicht zurück da kann man nicht
sagen das muss auf jeden fall
geschlossen bleiben wir müssen jetzt
noch andere sachen schließen würde dann
für sie bedeuten sie würden den mut
haben wieder hinzugehen selbst wenn die
zahlen weiterhin 20.000 pro tag
sind zu sagen dann machen wir's wieder
auge bietet schon das grundgesetz für
die bundesrepublik deutschland wenn man
keinen grund hat in grundrechte
einzugreifen dann darf man nicht in
grundrechte eingreifen da gibt es
überhaupt keine beliebigkeit auch keine
politische beliebigkeit wir sind alle an
den verhältnismäßigkeitsgrundsatz bei
unserem politischen entscheidungen
gebunden und deswegen weil alle so sagen
wir haben woche wird evaluiert und wenn
es nichts gebracht hat da muss noch mal
was draufgelegt werden so einfach ist
das nicht wir sind jeder der hier
anordnungen trifft in grundrechte
eingriff unterliegt einer ausführlichen
begründung ausführlichen begründet dass
manchmal helfen vielleicht nicht
auskennt bissingen da sitzen zu haben
aber jemand zumindest sitzen zu haben
der ein bisschen anders denkt in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und noch
einmal herr wissing gesagt da fehlt es
freie denken oder das freie denken
zulässt also s3 denken ist nicht nur bei
den freidemokraten gegeben dass gerade
auch die anderen und insofern wir haben
finde ich einen guten austausch und auch
einen guten streit sowohl in der
koalition aber eben auch mit der
demokratischen opposition werden schien
es nicht gemeinsam erreicht wenn nicht
wirklich alle an einem strang
sie sind sich schon relativ einig sie
lobte die kanzlerin die ganze spd oder
gestand ich sage jetzt auch mal an die
adresse von frau eisenmann die
kultusministerin und minister der länder
die sind doch näher dran die
ministerpräsidenten sind näher dran und
da ist es manchmal ganz gut wenn an
dieser stelle aus berlin nicht irgendwo
sondern ich sag jetzt mal so ein
patentrezept verbreitet wird
also ich schäme mich nicht dass ich sage
hört doch mal auf die die mit ihren
lehrerinnen und lernen täglich kontakt
haben und das vor ort besser einschätzen
können unsere aufgabe ist doch eine form
zu finden das zu bündeln erstmal weil
die menschen mitgehen müssen das heißt
es gibt einfach ein bedürfnis für
bestimmte dinge zu wissen die gelten
überall
es gibt aber auch das bedürfnis nicht
etwas übergestülpt zu bekommen was der
eine braucht der andere aber nicht weil
es eben nicht verhältnismäßig ist und da
gebe ich herrn bisschen recht ich habe
ja schon mal gesagt herr söder würde
glaube ich anders argumentieren wenn er
im land zu vertreten hätte in dem live
und jetzt ist es so dass er natürlich
gerne hätte es werden die anderen auch
machen und da
muss ich sagen es ist sicher schwierig
das in bayern jetzt zu handeln und das
da hat man sich auch nicht darüber zu
freuen oder sonst was die haben da eine
menge zu tun aber das muss deswegen
nicht aber sie sagen sie sagen es
natürlich schon vorher gerne auch dass
es in bayern schlecht meine drei söhne
lebt ja oft wert darauf wenn etwas in
bayern besser läuft und dann ist auch
nicht der erste der das auf alle anderen
sofort mit übertragen musste sondern
reisen jetzt müssen auch sagen an dieser
stelle muss er ach hier haben im
nachnamen den appell würden sie denn so
weit gehen allen schülern schülerinnen
und eltern in baden württemberg zu sagen
also bis weihnachten abgesehen jetzt
vielleicht von absoluten hotspots
bleiben die schulen offen
natürlich müssen wir dort schließen
wurden hotspot ist das kommt auch in
schulen an ich habe ja vorher die zahl
genannt
die kmk jetzt erhoben hat beim 106
komplett geschlossenen schulen von
41.000 aber natürlich ist es mit einer
garantie immer schwierig ich kann nur
sagen ich persönlich halte ist von
fehler und ich setze mich bei mir im
bundesland auch massiv dafür ein dass
kitas und schulen offen bleiben unter
pandemie bedingungen ja aber dass wir
aus den erfahrungen von märz und april
lernen und ich verweise mal auf 86
prozent der eltern zur deutschland trend
vor acht bis zehn tagen 86 prozent der
eltern sagen ja wir wollen die schulen
flächendeckend geöffnet aber nicht eine
garantie also sie sie sagen jetzt bei
uns das ist kein infektions herzig sagen
in winziger teil an schulen hat
überhaupt ein corona problem und sie
sagen die eltern wollen dass die schulen
offen bleiben sie ganz im land selbst
regeln können sie aussagen bleibt bis
weihnachten offen
naja für mainz aus meiner sicht ja
allerdings weiß ich nicht sagen jetzt
auch mal offen was die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz morgen oder
nächste woche macht ich kann nur
dringend dazu raten sich an den zahlen
zu organisieren zu orientieren und damit
deutlich zu machen wir schaffen auch
bildung während der pandemie das muss
die herausforderung sein von mir gibt's
diesen klaren billen
ich hoffe es gibt ihn aus allen
politischen ebenen genauso mir dass
diese zusage geben aber das wird nicht
ausreichen angesichts dessen dass ich
das nicht alleine entscheiden
danke frau eisenmann da geht gerade das
bild
flöten was aber kein böser wille ist wir
danken ihnen sehr für diese schalter
heute mit uns sagt die frau so flammen
die bald selber ministerpräsident sein
möchte tim sein möchte in baden
württemberg danke für das gespräch heute
abend und ich will ihn noch ein video
zeigen von der bundesregierung dass der
regierungssprecher steffen seibert unter
anderem geteilt und in die welt gesetzt
hat es geht um eine auseinandersetzung
mit dieser corona pandemie auf eine ganz
spezielle art und weise im werbespot der
uns alle dazu anhalten soll
disziplinierter zu sein in der krise
ich glaube das war im winter 2010 sicher
ist das ganze land auf uns schotter
ich war gerade 20 geworden studierte
maschinenbau in chemnitz als die zweite
welle kam
diesem alter will man doch feiern
studieren jemanden kennenlernen als
sowas oder mit freunden einen trinken
gehen
doch das schicksal hatte andere pläne
mit uns
[Musik]
wenn der unsichtbare gefahr bedrohte
alles woran wir glauben und das
schicksal dieses landes lag plötzlich in
sein
[Musik]
also fassen wir alle unser mut zusammen
und taten was von uns erwartet wurde
das einzig richtige
nichts absolut gar nichts war ein foul
wie die waschbären tage und nächte lang
leben wir auf unsere marge zu hause und
kämpften gegen die ausbreitung des
corona - unsere couch war die front
unsere geduld war unsere wasser
[Musik]
manchmal muss ich fast ein bisschen
schmunzeln wenn ich an diese zeit zurück
denke dass war unser schicksal so wurden
wir zu helden
damals
diesem corona winter 2010
ja so wurden wir damals zu corinna
helden norbert walter borjans reden
darüber dann rückblickend wie über ein
krieg ist die krise irgendwann
vergleichbar mit einem krieg na ja also
ich wäre vorsichtig mit solchen
begriffen aber ich meine wenn das das
heldentum ist das da gerade beschrieben
worden ist dann kann man auch schmunzeln
insofern ja es ist natürlich eine
riesige gesellschaftliche
herausforderung es ist etwas was einen
eindruck auf einen generation mit
sicherheit hinterlässt insofern ist das
ein schönes bild das der ältere mann
sich an diese zeit erinnert als etwas
das nicht einfach nur mal ein jahr
stattgefunden hat sondern das verändert
etwas in einem das glaube ich
deswegen ist es auch so wichtig noch
einmal auf dieses thema bildung zukommen
und referenzen reich zum heldentum ein
es ist nicht mein werbe spots haben
immer ihre ihre eigenarten ich finde ihn
ehrlich gesagt persönlich ganz gelungen
wissen haben sie gelacht oder es gibt ja
im netz auf viel kritik viele lachen
darüber finde es witzig da gibt es
gleichzeitig kritik auch die es stimmt
so einige analoge ich einerseits können
wir darüber sprechen ist die krise wie
ein krieg andererseits wie war das
nochmal mit deutschen helden im zweiten
weltkrieg eigentlich erzählen die so
über den zweiten weltkrieg am
volkstrauertag herr wissing
also ich glaube das ist ein bisschen
vereinfachen dieses dieser film so
einfach ist es ja nicht denn das macht
ja was mit menschen weil sie die
sozialen kontakte nicht haben was hier
passiert es sind ja wir wirklich setzen
jahren massive eingriff in unser
wirtschaftssystem das wird ja folgen
haben das ist ja nicht einfach so dass
man sagt wir sind jetzt helden weil wir
ein bisschen auf der couch sitzen und
wenn alles gut so einfach ist das nicht
und wir müssen uns schon sehr genau
überlegen was sind die nächsten schritte
wenn das noch monate geht dann möchte
ich nicht so alberne vorschläge würden
wir machen schule künftig in der kneipe
oder in der in der pizzeria die ist ja
sowieso geschlossen oder so was was
wasser altmaier jetzt gesagt hat ich
erwarte schon dass wir uns auch offen
und auch sehr sachlich und
faktenorientiert jetzt einem system
zuwenden mit denen wir diese krise so
bewerkstelligen können dass wir nicht am
ende ein kollateralschaden haben schauen
sie dieses gesundheitssystem in
deutschland ist hervorragend das ist
aber nur deshalb finanzierbar weil wir
ein
der stärksten volkswirtschaften der welt
sind wenn wir die ruinieren werden wir
in zukunft auch kein so stark ist sich
und finanzieren will dabei die
wirtschaftlichen schäden werden massiv
sein oder sie zu ruinieren
wir sind in punkt politik ist immer ein
abwägungsprozess und wir müssen auch die
wirtschaftlichen kollateralschäden die
entstehen können im blick haben und die
müssen auch in die abwägung mit rein
deswegen sage ich ja wenn wir evaluieren
müssen wir auch überlegen ob vielleicht
habe ich sagen was ja nicht was sie
sagen dann fertig geworden ist was man
hätte offenhalten können sie sagen es ja
nicht so allein sie sagen ja sie waren
ja davor dass die wirtschaft ruiniert
wird das heißt sind wir gerade dabei die
wirtschaftlichen schäden sind verheerend
schauen sich den bundeshaushalt an die
staatsverschuldung die muss ja wieder
zurückbezahlt werden manche träumen
schon von höheren steuern ich weiß gar
nicht wer die erwirtschaften soll
das ist nicht ohne was hier passiert und
manche haben sie den eindruck wenn wir
jetzt november hilfen bezahlen dann ist
der wirtschaftliche schaden ja schon
abgegolten läuft ja alles wie vorher
so ist das nicht in den betrieben sind
massive folgen zu erwarten und schauen
sie es geht auch nicht so dass wir
irgendwann ende november sagen ihr könnt
morgen oder übermorgen wieder aufmachen
die missbrauchen vorlaufzeit die
betriebe müssen wir auch wieder
hochgefahren werden
also dann haben wir dieses problem der
mittelbar betroffenen die ja zum teil
gar nicht entschädigt werden da
überwiegend nicht entschädigt werden was
da noch droht wir haben die
insolvenzantrags fristen verlängert und
wir laufen nicht auf eine insolvenzwelle
zu sondern eher auf einen insolvenz
tsunami wenn wir nicht irgendwann zu
einem system kommen das ausgewogenste
insolvenz tsunami wir sind dabei eine
wirtschaft zu ruinieren walter borjans
das macht einem angst vor allen dingen
mit blick auf das was sie immer im blick
hatten oder haben wollten den haushalt
mehr
das wird katastrophal im nächsten also
erst mal tun wir ja auch was für die
mittelbar betroffenen das muss man sagen
diese november hilfe und zieht sich
nicht bloß auf die die und über
schließen müssen sondern eben auch die
die zum beispiel zu liefern dass er
einen punkt der zweite punkt ja
natürlich man kann ich einfach nur mit
mit mittel mit geld von draußen so tun
als wenn der wirtschaftskreislauf läuft
es steht aber still
deswegen ist das ja der grund warum wir
nicht sagen ja wir machen mal für drei
vier monate etwas sondern wir versuchen
immer zu sehen schaffen wir bis zum ende
des monats eine wende die uns ermöglicht
mehr laufen zu lassen
und dann muss ich nur sagen ich gebe
herrn bisschen ja völlig recht dass er
sagt wir haben ein gutes
gesundheitswesen aber dann muss man auch
darüber reden dass all das was dieser
staat jetzt an auffangmöglichkeiten
bietet auch damit zu tun hat dass er
finanzierbar ist und dass er auch
tatsächlich jetzt steht das der agenda
steht in frage na ja also wenn ich
umgekehrt sage das erste vorüber ich
immer nachdenke ist die staatlichen
einnahmen zu senken dann wird er sich am
ende darin wird noch mal eine ganz
andere debatte gibt ihnen einen strich
drunter wasser geschlechter wir wissen
heute noch nicht das was uns eigentlich
in aussicht gestellt wurde nämlich wie
es dann anfang dezember weitergehen soll
vor allen dingen der gastwirt weiß es
nicht ob er wieder öffnen darf oder
nicht hoffnung können sie alle nicht
machen er walter bauer und sie sagen er
wird das noch mal in der verschärfung
landen vor weihnachten vor allen dingen
was möglicherweise kontakt kontakte in
der familie private kontakte angeht das
nehmen wir mit aus dieser runde
letzte frage an sicher weiter bei uns
gibt ein bisschen ärger mit einer ihrer
ministerin frau gefeiert
die verzichtet jetzt freiwillig auf
ihren doktortitel
trotzdem ist ja der vorwurf des betrugs
nicht ausgeräumt es geht weniger um
ihren doktortitel als um den vorwurf des
betrugs das heißt kann sie ministerin
bleiben wenn sich der betrug als betrug
rau stellt also franziska giffey hat
eine empirische doktorarbeit gemacht das
heißt also mit sehr vielen
datensammlungen datenauswertung
es ist also geliefert nein aber ich habe
mit ihr auch natürlich darüber
gesprochen und es hat eine intensive
prüfung vor einem jahr gegeben hat zu
einem einstimmigen ergebnis geführt dass
man es 34 stellen glaube ich kritisiert
hat aber dass man gesagt hat die ist
dass das urteil das ist eine anständige
doktorarbeit ist davon nicht betroffen
so jetzt ist das auf betreiben von
einigen seiten noch mal wieder neu
aufgerollt worden
sie hat finde ich einen sehr
respektablen entschluss gefasst und hat
gesagt ist ja was dann verzichte ich auf
die führung des doktortitels
und ich finde das ist ein klares wort
und das verdient unseren respekt und da
sehen sehr viele so dass es immer
ausgangspunkt für eine diskussion ist
davon scheitelpunkt ist er fertig weil
die öffentlichkeit in erst recht für für
weitere ämter diese anstreben ob sie
betrogen
es wird die kommission irgendwann
feststellen was ist dann kann sie dann
noch beispielsweise regierende
bürgermeisterin sein werden wenn sich
herausstellt sie hat betrogen ich habe
keinen anlass weil die kommission schon
mal geprüft hat jetzt hypothetisch zu
sagen was wäre wenn sie nicht prüft also
wir kennen das im augenblick wo in
bestimmten ländern immer wieder neu
ausgezählt wird ich sage jetzt mal es
gibt ergebnisse und die gelten erst mal
bis zum beweis des gegenteils und ich
glaube fest daran dass dieses urteil
auch bestand haben wird
dank herr walter borjans danke herr
wissing danke an die muntere diskussion
hier und wenn sie auch gleich nicht
besonders viele hoffnung ehrlicherweise
macht mit blick auf die nächsten
lockdown wochen möglicherweise lockte am
monate die uns bevorstehen ihnen dennoch
einen schönen rest abend bis nächste
woche am sonntag für die wurzeln
[Musik]